hello and welcome once again to gamespot
of Thrones I'm Lucy joined by Kate gray
hello and Dave jewett I'm here to yes
you are so fair warning we're going to
be discussing the crap out of the latest
episode of Game of Thrones so that's
season 6 episode fourth book of the
stranger if you haven't seen it turn
away now but if you have let's get into
it let's get a disappointment out of the
way we didn't see anything from terror
joy because you bastards but anyway some
awesome stuff did happen in this week's
episode so Dave why don't you kick off
so starting from the bottom this week in
the south we see Marjorie under more
torture but actually the torture this
time is just having to sit through the
high sparrows boring origin story hey
turn out he was a cobbler who just went
to a bunch of orgies and got sick of it
I admired the way that his story just
went from nought to 100 he was like
making shoes nice shoes oh jeez forgot
my shoes and became a priest mm-hmm
thanks mate she does however get to see
Loras in his dishevelled state but it
appears to be like a bit of a ploy from
the high Sparrow she believes that she's
been sent there to kind of break lorises
will I believe it's actually the other
way around hi sparrows quite clever chap
so I think that the fact that he's
allowed them to see each other is trying
to break them both kind of admit to
their sin but they're still locked up at
the end of the day they've been locked
up for a while I think I think they can
get comfortable you can tell by the yard
hello there Horace is here also is
really shameful bit how many months of
growth is that come on man and then susi
gatecrash is another small council
meeting and the first time that Cersei
Lannister and the queen of thorns agree
on anything is that we've got to get
they say we've got to get Marjorie out
before her walk of atonement they forget
about Loras again well if he's naked
everyone's basically seen it all that's
true but now they're trying to get the
Tyrells are me up to the high septum to
kind of take Marjorie back by force
coming for your Marjorie they'll be okay
we haven't forgotten about you except we
have a Commodores if it doesn't go as
planned
the sparrows have many friends in this
city will have Civil War many will die
many will die no matter what we do
better them than us
and then to the north and we're gonna
hold our hands up on this one because we
said it wasn't gonna happen we thought
John and Sansa would just pass like
ships in the night but no that was this
incredible reunion scene ah I got I
genuinely got shivers because it was
just so nice to see something good
happen in Game of Thrones to some of the
characters I mean to be fair we
predicted that it wouldn't happen but
that's because we've been let down so
many times we're finally coming around
to it and then he does it the other way
around so not off already will you go
where will we go if I don't watch over
your father's girls to come back and
murder me Melisandre officially confirms
that she is team John and she calls him
the prince that was promised so you know
she thinks he's this legendary warrior
and also we get you know complete just
confirmation from Brienne yeah I
executed Stannis so just take a moment
of silence r.i.p Stannis the Manas we
believed in you I didn't come true we
also get this incredible moment of
tormund Giantsbane and Brienne
immediately becoming the Internet's new
OTP like I just they were so cute and it
was just the best eyebrow acting in the
game and also we get one step closer to
bastard ball because Ramsey sends John a
really mean note really mean basically
it's basically the equivalent of I'll
see you in the playground yeah 3 30 come
alone sounds a lot more awful savagery
yeah except with I'll have 5,000 men
you'll have like 2,000 I'll do nasty
things to your sister yeah well scoop
out your eyes I didn't get have that
high school anyway at the veil my love
Littlefinger ah he's back where has he
been but he just proves to serve Royce
just how tightly he's got sweet Robin
wrapped around his little finger just a
throwaway comment gets Royce almost
checked out the moon door and then he
manages to convince Robin he doesn't
even have to do anything he just says
all right we're gonna we're gonna send
the troops to help Santa right and
Robin's like yeah you got me a falcon
I'm fine our Lord has spoken gather the
night of the Vale
time has come to join the fray and then
a pike Theon manages to just you know
bend the rules of space and time to get
that super quickly he returns to a
disgruntled Yara who is just sort of
like my brother's dead you know I risked
a whole lot to get to you and thien's
like okay well you know that was my
fault Ramsey broke me I'll help help you
now and I'll back your corner for the
upcoming Kingsmoot which are is
obviously standing for and then I last
stop in the north poor sure she tried to
do power play on Ramsey I mean don't
interrupt a man while he's peeling his
apples I rebuild it ah I think that's a
lesson for all of us and she ends up a
game just stabbed in the neck really
they my favorite coming from that was
somebody said for a man who can fly
human he can't peel an apple very well
well the fact that he just did one stab
someone and used that knife to peel
another you know whose blood splatter on
one up and was gonna get fresh one I
mean it was kind of obvious that she was
gonna die she's looking at that knife
and he obviously knew he's quite wise to
that kind of thing but she wasn't going
to leave that room any other way so
alright failed seduction there it's okay
what happened in Essos so we start off
in marine with Tyrion currently trying
to make peace with the slavers of
slavers Bay which you know it's named
after slavers they're probably not going
to be too keen but he gives them seven
years to sort their stuff out but Miss
Sunday and grey worm former slaves
obviously aren't too impressed with that
and it starts to sort of brew into what
might turn out to be a little bit of
civil unrest for Tyrion so hopefully the
nurse will come back and sort that out
over in vase Dothraki we've got the
broad trip finally getting to its
destination finding tenaris but they
start with a bit of lad banter where
they going your old yeah well you're
rude so the cracks start to show also
with little cracks in Dora's arm because
he's got great yeah Daria finds out and
Diaries like word and touch me and it
gets even more lad banter II so they
drop their weapons when they going into
the city and all our weapons in vase
Dothraki but Dario is very attached to
his boob lady knife so brings it in and
then he stabs a guy and then it turns
out that that's super obvious so then he
officer rock on the guy's head luckily
the curl doesn't actually care he says
[ __ ] I go and you know that's done what
he actually has to attend to as much
more pressing what's going to happen to
donairs so generis is standing there
with a smug little smirk on her face and
you're thinking okay she's got a plan
but what's going to happen and you think
what is going to happen is that she just
insults all of the khalasar and she says
you know she threatens them she insults
there we go she's like you're not going
to touch me I'm Khaleesi and I'm gonna
be the starting in the mouse world and
all that kind of nonsense luckily she
doesn't recite her titles again and
you're thinking this is a terrible idea
she's going to beat her up then she sets
them on fire so that's a much better
plan and then she comes out and she's
naked again and she manages to hypnotize
the entire dashka lean with her nipples
she goes full Targaryen basic oh yeah oh
yeah
I felt like this episode was kind of
book ended as usual by the best bets it
definitely got a bit slow in the middle
but there are some real big talking
points let's kick off with my new
favorite couple let's just talk about
tormund Giantsbane and Brienne of Tarth
so are they really called Giants hey hey
the bear and the maiden fair uh so I
think like this is for me as well
because you read the books you kind of
get more of an insight into Brienne and
just kind of how tragic her life has
been like she's mockingly referred to as
Brienne the beauty because in the book
she's you know gwendoline christie is my
goodness like I love that woman but like
in the books obviously right Breanna's
meant to have really bad crooked teeth
and she's meant to be just hideous so
the call of Brienne the beauty
constantly mocked as a child her
betrothed dies and then at one point her
dad you sort of gives up on trying to
marry off to people even though she's
the only heir of the house tath and it's
also sad like she gets all dressed up
and these these big bullies like just
you know just completely rip her a new
one and just call it awful names and
like that's why she falls in love with
Renly because he's the only one who ever
showed her like a hint of kindness so
basically seeing tormund like he sees
her for the first time in his first
reaction is oh yeah okay that i browse
go and he's eating what looks like a
burrito in a very sexual way yeah you
could be this now it's a prime time just
mexican food at the wall look like
everything is well about that thing is
just first of all like Brienne's
reaction cuz i guess she never takes our
stuff seriously right she's she's got
that arm and she's like mmm but then
dolorous EDD it's just like all right
hey he was he wants this to happen
matchmaker head so do we think other of
DB vice and David Benioff are they gonna
give us just just like a little bit of
happiness there's a better not be a one
episode like little funny thing I want
this to be a full-blown romance i want
an entire episode devoted to their
courtship and their marriage and their
babies oh dang i think i just gotta
probably fight and have a lot of sex
oday why he's like he's a wildling and
she's just wants to she's just
acting son sir Torin ship Giantsbane
okay if he can make it with a giant then
you know he's a different kind of Jones
been trying is that he killed the giant
you made it on a bane though it may so
Tom and all says that he had it off with
a bear yeah but um Egret said that like
not that of course i didn't have as much
biologically um but it's interesting
like thinking about this the bear and
the maiden fair is like it's a song with
in Game of Thrones it's the title of an
episode and there's a lot of kind of
parallels like if you see in the
relationship like re and hound and the
Hound to be the bear and she would be
the maiden fair but this one is like
Brienne's finally the maiden fair she's
got her bare tormance probably got a lot
of diseases though she can wash him so
we finally get to see the son's friend
John reunion that we didn't think was
going to happen and it was beautiful and
they hugged and we cried a little bit we
got old Terry we ride we cried you cry
um but it's it's george RR martin we
don't have a beautiful moment like that
and without being self or something
utterly horrible and heartbreaking but
if this is going to lead into basketball
then you may be one of them is gonna die
that's a big thing who's gonna die
they're all gonna die enjoyed ones you
can do again yeah so it starts off with
John sort of being like I can't do it
I've lost all faith in myself remember
that time when I was like totally emo
back at Winterfell well I want to do it
again I'm sorry and Sansa sort of has to
be the one to bring him back up and go
for God's sake regret our ancestral home
has been taken from us our brothers in
custody everyone else is missing and at
first John isn't very convinced by this
but then he gets a letter from ramsey
that's threatening to Sansa it's
threatening Rick on who's now in
Ramsay's custody it's threatening John
is threatening the wildlings you know
he's ticking all the boxes and that gets
John riled up and then he's like yeah
let's go let's do it bastard Bowl 2016
let's go so that's where we're at at the
moment but there's a lot of interesting
questions about what's going to happen
next firstly we're going to see
basketball right right yeah yes I'm
totally gearing up to that I've already
asked is one of them going to die but
come on guys who's
die first Oh Matt Ramsey old ines I'm
kind of like like the pivotal moment
right oh yeah right some something I
happened around go still rip him up
we're actually I'm considering you know
who's gonna kill Ramsey who's the most
satisfying person to do him in finally
because he's got plot armor at the
moment he's invincible who's gonna find
me stick a sort in his tiny little neck
I'd love it to be just like a complete
wild card you having to get like
squished by 11 yeah good um my favorite
question is Sansa pregnant now she's had
a lot of uh well with Ramsey I hope not
I'll be all for and although that means
her son would be the trueborn air yes so
so he'd have a better claims to throw in
ramsey maybe cuz he's a stark and a
Bolton yeah but if it if he was ramsey
street when I might mean the Ramsey
wouldn't go after her mom is Ramsey he's
killed babies he's killed his own dad
he's gonna kill her baby before then he
dun think he's had a baby yet mmm he's
killed he's killed on babies all things
and finally Sansa mmm AKA elaine stone
maybe she's the real Lady Stoneheart not
as in book ladies now on though but she
has a heart of stone now because
everyone's betrayed her yes I'm gonna
become with a spear of vengeance that I
don't know what I bloody hope so so it
looks like it's actually Danny's turn to
do something interesting this episode
finally leave long enough like three
season although this is a pilot Rick
she's done before the whole emerging
from the fire thing but after you know
she she got her new Tosh clean best
friend oh yeah just the new BFF is like
a you want to help me and I think the
help pretty much consisted of just
fitting the temple will oil don't know
how no one saw or smelled it but I don't
know one like slip on I just imagine one
of the cars going into go blue wet floor
sign just process posted up suddenly
melting asked as she sets the whole
place on fire just emerges from the
flames again like we've seen flaming
Danny before dude a fire in the flames
yeah we'll carry on but what do we think
is Danny gonna do with a new army
because the whole
Panesar's bowing to her now oh I feel
kind of sorry for Tyrion cuz he's worked
so hard known as do all his long scenes
about diplomacy and politics I feel like
she's just gonna go straight back there
with the khalasar but it's not even like
just one cows are it's like all of them
right yeah she's just gonna wander back
here like oh hi um you told the slavers
what kill everybody but also I'm kind of
disappointed not disappointed but like
one trick muddy pony you do the fire
trick the fire trip when she could have
done more if she just she seemed to just
know that it was gonna be fine yeah it's
interesting though because there are
someone picked us up on the subreddit
there's an interview George RR martin
when he's like yeah the Targaryens are
not completely invulnerable to fire but
it seems like show yeah Targaryen show
universes unless they reveal some kind
of Dragon magic in the next episode was
actually what happened was just outside
really yeah I just called him over and
been like can you see outside like an
uber yeah speaking of like waste of time
yeah like jores and Dario's trip was
pretty much wasted the only only thing
to happen I like she was what I gonna be
able to do that without their help yeah
they did nothing the trip basically
equated to you know Dario finding out
that George got grayscale watch things
gonna happen between those who now hey
bonding happened Dave buddy cop movie
how Tommy I was like please don't touch
me or my nice knife Jorah you're gross
that was the bonding oh but also can we
just talk joris found yeah why like I
didn't know it doesn't say in the book
the Dale from king of the hill train
Jorah moment he is Bacchus sans that guy
and fails as well doesn't even do a good
job yeah i mean like oh great like I go
who's been like just writing at the head
of a khalasar but God knows how many
years just would be used to sad and
enjoy didn't even aim it properly with
his gubby rarest i'm about yeah but
they're really saying drop is like the
most pathetic character no I feel I
don't feel bad i can't even felt bad for
joy that nearly felt bad but then I
is an underdog I want him to rise up
he's got gray scale no I've it we've
seen one gray scale survivor before yeah
she dead yeah she's dead there's been a
mistake that was different circumstance
I reckon Jorah like his last thing he'll
do before he completely dies or turns or
just be him doing something for Daenerys
and then she'll be like oh I was wrong
about you you are loyal to me then he'll
die she he'll shout like in battle with
loads of her enemies like I love you and
she'll be like ok well maybe maybe he'll
do you like the frozen thing right where
he's turning to stone just as someone
like stabzor and he shatters and that's
the end of joram and she cries over his
shattered body and then she's like
groups all right season six there's a
lot of stuff going on characters moving
in I don't know like directions I didn't
really expect them to Denarius going
full Targaryen is probably one of them
Kate where do you think should go from
here well to be honest it's taken her a
bloody long time to get where she is
she's meant we go into Westeros has she
forgotten they did sort of say oh she's
she's still going yeah worry she's still
go to Westeros yeah don't snow so it
might not be a while you know season one
she declared her intention to go west
and she's been going east like the
entire time but you know she's finally
got the ball rolling she's finally
become the burninator she's added that
to her ridiculously long cv hopefully
now she's going to head back to marine
with the dosh colleen and all those
calluses behind her actually you know
giving her some force for once rather
than like a handful of slaves against
you know all the people that live in
Essos and you know I'm kind of hoping
she'll have another one of those Mesa
moments whatever Mesa is in Dothraki
to be honest Terry ins sort of quite
slow burning pun intended and she tends
to come along and just you know get her
way by shouting and getting all kind of
rabid so she's probably not going to
agree with his sort of more diplomatic
plans and I kind of wish he did because
Terrans put in a lot of work but she's
not really the kind of person to
compromise so sorry Korean oh I can't
wait though if she does take the
khalasar over just then versus sons of
the harpy and maybe she'll let the
Dragons go out finally Oh get some
sunshine Tyrion was bonding with one of
them mmm so maybe I'm a charioteer just
chill with the with the dragon wild
today which ruins all of his hard work
he's gonna do some babysitting yeah yeah
dragon has three heads Ramsey at this
point I mean like not an episode has
gone by where he hasn't brutally
murdered at least one person this week
sadly it was all sure who got it in the
neck you forgot about well I think it
one didn't but I mean it just kind of
feels like they're really trying to
hammer home that like he is the bad guy
he's just rewards are coming so what's
interesting is the theory going around
on the subreddit so shadow to user Dan
damps beer for posting as a few days ago
but it's quite interesting to see like
Ramses position in basketball isn't may
be as secure as he thought it would be
so we assumed that you know like Ramses
got the superior force he has Winterfell
which is a great defensive position and
then the umbers come round and they just
drop off Rick on right Rick on is there
like the key like linchpin the linchpin
of Ramsey and that's why Ramsey kind of
feel safe that he can move cuz he has
this like weird alliance with the umbers
where ours this is like a bit of book
background here the umbers are fiercely
loyal to the stocks like that I think
the head of the house gets killed at the
red wedding trying to protect Robb Stark
where is in this they just just did a
complete 180 out of nowhere seemingly um
so it's already a bit weird anyway
there's also some reasoning as to that
that dog's head isn't shaggy dog when
you see that when you want a scene again
it just sort of like recon doesn't
really react he saw it just goes like
you know it's it doesn't like if he's
he's got a really special bond with that
annum
like even seeing its dead head even if
he died like a day or so go would still
be devastating yes i'm holding out that
that's still not shaggy dog and
seriously people on the subreddit have
gone measurements the whole kind of
thing and people are really convinced
that that's not shaggy dog so by giving
recon up to ramsey ramsey now thinks
it's safe to leave Winterfell which is
why you know busted balls could take
place outside mm-hmm but did they know
did the umbers rather know that the veil
were gonna end up giving their troops to
Sansa and John my friends in the north
Tony Sanchez escape Winterfell I expect
she's headed to Castle black where her
brother serves as Lord Commander but she
won't be safe there not with the
Bolton's after her we should help her
that was my instincts as well because
there was a really interesting theory
about like where's little finger bean
has he already like chatted with the
umbers and said I'll give you the
support the troops and that's why the
umbers are sort of pretending to ally
with and that's why little fingers come
back now and been like hey i just i mean
off the top of my head you want to do
this yeah it's a bird I'm the Lord of
umber when he was talking surrounds the
last episode didn't seem like he enjoyed
being there Wow refuse to take any of
you refused to break it off also if
osha's been there the umbers made that'd
be really big deal about hating
wildlings I like fighting wailings been
doing it all my life but there were too
many of them for us to be back along but
she's a wildling so why didn't they just
kill her they didn't need her anymore
they had Rick on its room so do you
think this hold any water I think it's a
dangerous strategy bringing you know the
key to the north or one of the many keys
to the north into the house of someone
who stabs people for fun a lot of the
time mmm so I reckon they've got to have
some really solid plan about what
they're gonna do I think it's going to
be a beautiful moment in basketball if
it suddenly turns out that you know the
inside betrays him so you know we've
seen the troops to yeah if he goes
outside Winterfell to go and fight John
and then when he turns around there's
just all these humble flags everywhere
well probably stark flags everywhere and
he's like wait a second
numbers just had sort of like a
reversible yeah I'd like um buzz one
side in it yeah mid-battle I love if
they just like pulled like a cord and it
just unfurled like Matilda doctoral
Matilda oh I can't wait for that if
that's not true it's gonna be
heartbreaking because I won't wreck on
to be okay recon hair well I like a
little finger convinced Sansa to like
wed the Bolton's so he might have had
that plan in action all that time you
thinking you'll go get John be like yo
Sansa's hanging out here we need your
help we've got the umbers on board and
now since Sansa escaped that's kind of
thrown like a wrench into his plans
who's that ok how can I adapt to this ok
we'll use Ric on the only thing is
what's little fingers endgame why is he
doing be the best cuz he is maybe like I
could it just be worn over marry Sansa
yeah but now he's got John who's you
know I mean little finger doesn't know
that technically he's the bastard so
could he be the board of the north well
I've seen that maybe Santa might be able
to legitimize him wouldn't that be
beautiful the thing is as well like
little finger doesn't know John died so
yeah yeah he still would have had to
keep his Nights Watch oath mm-hmm so he
would have been that wouldn't been a
risk he would silly Lord Commander yeah
basically i'm pretty sure Littlefinger
is doing this for power maybe money
probably Sansa but will it play out for
him or will it play out for the Starks
for once time now as always for death of
the week i'm gonna offer my my candidate
oh sure I mean we said earlier don't
interrupt a guy as he's peeling his
apples well interrupt a guy if you're
gonna do that to him maybe yeah I mean
genuinely I don't know why I thought
that her seduction would work in the
Ramsey was totally into it and he was
like alright just have a bit of sex and
then get on with my day she said Iran
told about seven minutes screen time of
this season I know I mean I well she
vanished in like was season three and
then she hasn't really been needed now
that reckons a porn in the game so Rick
technically Dario's naked lady dagger
killed a go mmm but you've got on my the
quick thinking of that event so stabbed
him they realize that this body will
arouse suspicion if it's found and
they'll be like a mad hunt for
interlopers so he just grabs a big heavy
bit of concrete and caves his head in
quite you know thoroughly like just
maybe like two hits too many news make
it slightly uncomfortable filter still
dead it's pretty clever I mean nobody
looks for a start stab wound on a
headless man so we're all worried that
Daenerys only get stuff done when her
dragons are there to back her up like
her bodyguards or whatever but it turns
out dragon mama can make her own fire so
that that whole scene was kind of what's
going to happen we don't know her plan
she did that actual sitcom thing of
going I have a plan cut to black and we
were like what is it why don't we not
get to know and I thought her plan was
just gonna be to talk but no it turns
out she's just wants to crucify the
dudes who were threatening to rape her
so it's the ultimate response to like a
gross kat Korner kind of wish that I
could do that sometimes but her smug
smug made it all the more delicious
time now for another spoiler warning if
you didn't watch the next time on Game
of Thrones so you have no idea what's
coming up in the next episode which is
the door time to look away because we're
going to be discussing that making some
predictions what's going to happen in
the next episode okay do you want to
kick things off with Sansa and little
finger yes so we saw that little thing
is going to be in the next episode again
and through the magic of really fast
Westeros transport you know has to meet
up with Sansa which I was quick
especially cuz it took us so long to get
anywhere so we know that there's going
to be five thousand men versus two
thousand men in bastard Bowl but maybe
it won't be that unfair a fight if the
veil and they're well-trained if
slightly boring men join in so Santa
who's leading the fight to most people
surprise because John has no backbone
and also died she meets Littlefinger the
dude who sort of accidentally married
her off to Ramsay Bolton and that didn't
go very well for her but it's likely
they're going to make up because first
of all little finger has the men santa
needs and second of all Littlefinger
always gets his way especially if it
happens to be the daughter of his creepy
dead crush and Dave well it looks like
area the assassin is going to get her
first team and contract we see her given
what appears to be a bottle of poison
hmm but then ish but then she is told
does death only come for the wicked and
leave the decent behind that's
interesting who could it be he's gotta
be someone in old town right well that's
the thing like this could be the start
of her crisis of conscience like maybe
shouldn't expect that she would have to
kill the innocent yeah but what appears
to be good people in the last person she
killed was so Meryn Trant who definitely
deserved it so this might kind of clash
with her moral compass of who she
believes deserves death mm-hmm if
they're not on her list she doesn't
really want to kill them right yeah but
they're just bad people yeah and finally
we get to see more brand more bran to be
honest I've been enjoying the Brian
segments just because you know one step
closer you enjoy power of joy so yeah
alright you would've enjoyed it
regardless of Brad
so in this we can see the bronze walking
so that obviously suggests that it's a
green dream because obviously we can't
walk in real life also you can see
mirror trying to wake him up so that's
kind of interesting because is he has he
gone dreaming by himself without the
three-eyed Raven and that's why you
can't wake up because if we see like
he's with the night's king maybe the
night's king is like instead him into a
dream and he can't leave that's creepy
well what's interesting is what dream
like what is he looking at so we could
see like the big army of the others
mm-hmm they seem to be like at the
three-eyed Ravens kind of place because
they can't seem to go past one line
because the magic that was so powerful
or whatever so I think maybe he's gone
back to the original like the original
long the long night which is where the
others came down and it was like a time
of darkness and the long winter and
famine and people like the first met
almost died but then they rallied
together in the battle for the dawn with
the first people so there's like those
green people as well and that's when as
or a high as well wielding light bringer
came to kind of put an end to the long
night so it'd be interesting to see if
brands gone back to look at that
especially with the the revelation room
this week that Melisandre is like yeah
John's definitely the prince that was
promised what I want to know is why is
he looking at that and not looking at
what's inside the tower I reckon it
might be that bran goes I want to look
at more terror of joy stuff because I
want to confirm our + l equals Jake's
bran is all of us come on now Brian but
in unguided meditation he just randomly
picks at a memory and then has to watch
it yeah he doesn't know how to use the
remote Simon an man is bran Oh confirmed
so there we are that was booked at the
stranger Kate what did you make of this
week's episode definitely better than
last week's episode some interesting
things happened no one super exciting
died the fire bit was nice maybe
lingered for a bit too long on the
nudity but you know they're trying to
make a point so that's fine like two
points oh so yeah overall I thought it
was a good day I enjoyed it um I've told
people i think it's the third
best episode so far okay as you
mentioned earlier it's bookended by like
the two greatest parts and then the
middle kind of just feels like more
setup bit a Courtin yep more badass
things are gonna come guys just keep on
waiting that's really what we're doing
now waiting for badass stuff yeah I mean
poor dawn again seems it seems like just
one is just right on the back burner um
high Sparrow I'm just sort of a little
bit I feel like that's plotting on a
little bit too long it's nice to see
Cersei and Elena kind of team um home
but I am excited next week more
Littlefinger is he basically he's my
he's my one true love yeah but if you
want to join us make sure to come back
to youtube.com slash gamespot next
Monday also you can come find us on
iTunes if you'd like to listen to just
the audio version make sure to search
the itunes store for gamespot of Thrones
you can also follow us on twitter i'm at
least II James games I'm at how not to
draw and I am at a regular Dave we'll
see you next week
you